are we rolling great I live my life a
quarter mile at a time we had such high
hopes for Doolittle and that was all
thanks to you Robert Downey jr. it
looked like it would be an exciting
adventure movie about the classic hero
who could talk to animals standing in
front of a boy asking him to love her
okay I'm one of the impression printing
out the wrong pages but the trailer
didn't tell us anything about what to
expect this movie was confusing and at
times he looks confused yourself there
were so many characters and so many
storylines that we could barely keep up
plus some of those jokes made us
seriously uncomfortable this movie
crossed the line more than once critics
and audiences haven't been too pleased
with Doolittle despite its huge budget
and all-star cast and they're pointing a
finger at the movies odd scenes and
off-putting jokes keep watching as we
reveal the 10 strangest things about
Doolittle oh and by the way this video
contains loads of spoilers don't say we
didn't warn you
put me in the movie or it's down e for
dessert there's no doubt that Robert
Downey jr. is a great actor and he's no
stranger to having a British accent he
was a huge success when he played
Sherlock Holmes in 2009 and 2011 but the
number one complaints and all the movie
reviews is his accent as Doctor Dolittle
we aren't quite sure what happened here
maybe the movie didn't spring for an
accent coach which is surprising
considering Doolittle's huge budget
maybe they wanted dr. Doolittle to have
a mystery accent but they missed the
mark he has a bit of a Welsh accent and
he spends most of the movie mumbling but
it also sounds a little British and
Scottish there are even moments where he
sounds like he might have an Irish or
Indian accent at one point we could have
sworn we heard it to make an accent it's
a huge contrast to the British accents
that Rex Harrison had in the 1967
version he always sounded posh and
articulate but Downey is hard to
understand through most of the new movie
it goes from Annoying to downright
distracting pretty quickly we are the
first to admit that we appreciate a good
pun in fact historically puns used to be
considered one of the most intelligent
types of humor
cosmetic there's a story you couldn't
make that oh how that has changed
one of the biggest critiques of the
humor in Doolittle is that the script
tries too hard to be funny they cram in
as many jokes as possible most of which
don't land like they're supposed to and
when they attempt to use a pun they fall
flat one of the best examples is the
scene with the whales dr. Dolittle's
main enemy is mud fly Queen Victoria's
aide there's a scene where they are
fighting on board Doolittle ship a pod
of whales shows up to help the good
doctor one whale tells his friends that
he can't believe he is flipping them off
okay we got a good chuckle out of that
weibull's have flippers flipping someone
off usually involves the middle finger
and is a really rude gesture but the
joke didn't make a lot of sense in that
context especially not for kids we're
gonna need a bigger shark I think you
meant to say boat it's pretty clear that
Doolittle is a kids movie the humor and
all the talking animals are really
geared toward making children laugh of
course we know that most kids movies
sneak in plenty of adult humor Doolittle
is no exception but this next joke might
have taken things a little too far Yoshi
is a polar bear played by John Cena
dr. Dolittle encounters Yoshi on his
travels you would probably expect a
character voiced by a famous wrestler to
be all tough and confident and polar
bears can be vicious animals but Yoshi
is full of anxiety he's got a lot of
issues and this Arctic animal hates
being cold he wants to go someplace warm
Yoshi makes a joke that his father left
when he was young to chase some seals he
never came back
this joke seems pretty dark for a kids
movie first of all what about all the
kids who can relate and second poor
Yoshi jokes about absent fathers are
made in movies all the time but was
Doolittle the right place for this one I
have nipples Greg can you milk me
overall the humor in Doolittle is mostly
slapstick and geared toward kids there
are a lot of jokes about rear-ends and
related things but more than once
Doolittle gets dark it's not just
Yoshi's tragic backstory the squirrel is
voiced by Craig Robinson he is one
hilarious comedic actor you might
recognize him from his roles in Seth
Rogen movies or from the office he
definitely brings his signature humor to
this erratic little squirrel brought to
dr. Dolittle by Tommy who is played by
Harry Collett Tommy is a boy who doesn't
want to hurt animals and he was being
pressured into duck hunting he
accidentally hit Spain with his bullet
and dr. Dolittle saves the squirrels
life it's clear he is suffering from
post-traumatic stress he's anxious and
has tons of flashbacks PTSD is a real
disorder and it's no joke he can be
really scary to relieve traumatic
incidents it's possible that Dolittle
went a little too far with Fleming's
injury film reviewers have a lot of
negative things to say about Dolittle
but one good thing that many of them
agree on is Jason Mantzoukas Jason was
in The Dictator and has also appeared on
hit shows like Brooklyn nine-nine and
the good place it's pretty much a
guarantee that Jason can make any role
funny as he proved and do little Jason
plays James the Dragonfly this is one
dramatic bug
James has relationship drama with his
aunt girlfriend which leads to a ton of
funny scenes the Dragonfly finds out
that his girlfriend is marrying a
scorpion is that even possible in the
real world anyway he is super jealous of
the scorpion he asks what the new bug
has that he doesn't and suggests it's
his big stinger big stinger is
definitely a euphemism for another body
part this probably went over the heads
of most of the kids in the audience but
all the adults knew exactly what James
was talking about you got the memo right
today we're just gonna mix things up and
reenact some classic okay you cool with
that
[Music]
we love that there are so many famous
stars and do little it was fun to see
who would pop up next Emma Thompson had
a huge role and so did rami malek
but we also heard from Octavia Spencer
Tom Holland Ralph Fiennes and even
Selena Gomez even the humans were really
famous Michael Sheen and Antonio
Banderas were the main bad guys but this
huge cast was part of the movie's major
issues there were a ton of characters to
keep up with and most of them didn't
advance the plot each new animal had
their own backstory and didn't work
together to make a cohesive movie
audiences have complained about getting
the whiplash while trying to keep up the
movie moved so quickly from one
character to the next that it's really
confusing
it was like the movies creators just
added characters so they could get more
big names in it's the main reason why
Dolittle has an under 20% rating on
Rotten Tomatoes we could have traded a
few less stars for a lot more plot which
scene has everyone grossed out keep
watching to find out how the finale went
way over the line it's so fluffy I'm
going to die Doctor Dolittle takes care
of almost every animal he meets he loves
animals and is dedicated to helping them
all animals except one that is dr.
Dolittle has a sworn enemy
this isn't Queen Victoria's advisor or a
king rasullah no dr. Dolittle's arch
nemesis is a grisly mean tiger named
Barry Barry is voiced by the incredible
Ralph Fiennes you probably know him best
as Lord Voldemort's from the Harry
Potter movies he plays such a great
villain for a lot of reasons that don't
entirely add up dr. Dolittle has to
fight Barry it's more than a trial by
combat it's a full-on gladiator style
scene that feels really out of place
even the kids in the audience know that
things are going to get grisly this
scene is really dark and it feels out of
place in a movie full of quips we also
can't help but feel that it's a little
cliche fighting a tiger hasn't that been
done in lots of movies before do I have
the role well you know actually you see
there are plenty of genuinely funny
moments in Dolittle some of those
one-liners had us laughing pretty hard
but some of the other jokes made our
brains do somersaults one of those jokes
has to do with the Ducks first of all
the entire scene with Tommy hunting
looks like the classic video game duck
hunt
it's definitely meant for the adults in
the audience and we enjoyed the
nostalgic reference but another duck
joke wasn't as easy to understand
oscar-winner Octavia Spencer voices a
duck named dab-dab
she gets spit on in one scene and she
says not to worry because it will just
slide right off this is referencing the
old Seine water off a duck's back
but you have to know something about
ducks to get it ducks have really oily
feathers that cause water to slide off
but some kids don't know that yet so the
joke didn't land it seems like the
script was just trying too hard to
include extra jokes we're back to James
the Dragonfly with this next moment that
went too far the bugs in Dolittle are no
joke and James is more than a little
peculiar no wonder his girlfriend wants
to marry someone else James finds out
that his girlfriend who is an aunt is
set to marry a scorpion James is
heartbroken but he doesn't just cry and
eat a pint of dragonfly ice cream he
totally loses it now the yang colony is
a tightly knit family and when Jason
shows up to destroy the wedding it looks
like another much more adult film this
scene is straight out of The Godfather
they even have the wedding like the
famous line about coming to the
Godfather on the day of his daughter's
wedding things get really gruesome James
is set on making a bad situation much
worse this whole bug mafia scene is
pretty funny but it's definitely dark
this is one unstable dragonfly as funny
as he is the aunt probably made the
right choice in choosing someone else
great dr. Doolittle is looking for a
cure for Queen Victoria and it's from a
certain tree at the end of the movie he
has defeated the bad guys and found what
he was searching for but there is a
dragon guarding that tree and things
take a quick turn for the worst
Doolittle figures out that this dragon
isn't just depressed
he's clogged up and we aren't talking
about his nose now we know veterinarians
to do some gross stuff and we didn't
need to see Doolittle do an exam of the
Dragons of rear end he starts pulling
out lots of items from the Dragons
derriere
there are human bones and armor there's
even a set of bagpipes this seemed made
everyone in the audience uncomfortable
and just when you think it's over it
gets worse
how can anything get weirder than Robert
Downey jr. sticking his hand inside a
CGI dragon during this exam the dragon
passes gas in a loud way right and
Doolittle's face we're just glad this
wasn't one of those forty movies with
smell effects did you enjoy watching the
Doolittle film tell us what you thought
about the movie in the comments ten
times Doolittle went way too far that's
a wrap
thanks for thanks for liking and
subscribing see you next time
you